dans l'actualité ce soir
écoles fermées et manifestations la
grève dans la fonction publique a été
plutôt bien suivi près d'un agent d'état
sur trois a cessé le travail selon le
ministère le double pour les personnels
de l'éducation selon les syndicats et ce
soir nicolas sarkozy l'a annoncé
lui-même le service minimum d'accueil
facultatif jusque là sera obligatoire
dans toutes les communes un projet de
loi sera déposé avant l'été
la chine s'inquiète pour les barrages
après le tremblement de terre 400
réservoir d'eau présentent des risques
près de l'épicentre une jeune femme de
22 ans a été sauvé après trois jours
sous les décombres
bonne surprise pour l'économie française
la croissance a été plus forte que prévu
en 2007 et elle s'est accélérée au
premier trimestre 2008
faut-il privilégier la vie à tout prix
une mère réclame réparation à l'hôpital
après la naissance de sa fille
lourdement handicapée
le bébé avait été réanimée contre la
volonté de ses parents
enfin les sciences avec cette découverte
géologique la méditerranée c'est bien
asséché complètement il ya 5 millions
d'années d'où le dépôt d'épaisses
couches de sel au fond de la mer
explications à la fin de ce journal
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous des lycéens
des parents et des fonctionnaires en
majorité des enseignants
le mot d'ordre de grève a donc été assez
largement suivie aujourd'hui difficile
de trancher la traditionnelle bataille
de chiffres mais on estime qu'entre 40 %
et deux tiers des enseignants ont cessé
le travail dans les manifestations
reportage mallory aoudou et jean-marie
le quartier avec notre bureau à
marseille un service public qui c'est
niet
c'est ce qu'ils sont venus dénoncer à
paris ils étaient cinquante mille selon
les organisateurs 18000 selon la police
avec un mot d'ordre non aux suppressions
de postes sur les quelque 23 mille
suppressions prévues dans la fonction
publique la moitié concerne l'éducation
les enseignants et surtout les lycéens
forme et donc le gros du cortège
il y aura plus lee daniels y aura plus
de toutes les options qui permettent à
des délais qui sont pas spécialement
intéressé par l'école justement
d'ordonner en fuite
on voit bien que dans le primaire par
ailleurs les effectifs augmentent et ses
élèves de primaire ils finiront bien par
année au lycée un jour dans le primaire
justement les professeurs étaient très
mobilisées comptant entre 46 et 63 % de
grévistes des slogans ironiques pour
s'opposer au nouveau programme
ils sont exactement calé son école jules
ferry et on voudrait le rappeler n'est
qu'à 50 ans dinka d'âge au crb à leurs
côtés les fonctionnaires de la santé de
la culture ou des douanes dénonce la
même logique comptable et le manque de
concertation
on est averti ça ne passait derrière
mais on nous demande de nous un peu plus
que derrière on a aussi de la sorte de
galles qui qui s'amenuisent et on
n'avait plus de temps pour on sait qu'il
y aura plus de 30 mille suppressions de
postes en 2009
si on va arriver ça quelques années
après formi suppressions de postes c'est
un chiffre énorme jamais atteint dans
notre pays et on ne peut pas faire ce
type de réforme sans parler des
objectifs
les organisations syndicales se dit
satisfaite par la mobilisation dans les
cortèges de province ici à marseille le
défilé a rassemblé entre 7000 et 30000
personnes
de quoi établir un rapport de force
avant de nouvelles actions notamment
jeudi prochain autour des retraites
au total dans toute la france 300 mille
personnes ont manifesté selon les
syndicats deux cent mille selon la
police
images ici de rouen où ils étaient
quelques milliers
grosse mobilisation aussi à grenoble
entre sept et quinze mille personnes ont
défilé
un peu plus tôt une manifestation non
déclarée en préfecture s'était achevée
avec des affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre quatre
lycéens ont été interpellés et au soir
de ce mouvement la principale
information je vous le disais est venue
de l'elysée nicolas sarkozy lui-même
annonce que le service minimum d'accueil
dans le primaire va devenir obligatoire
on va l'évoqué dans un instant d'abord
voyons comment il a été appliqué
aujourd'hui ce service minimum il était
encore facultatif c'était aux communes
que revenait le choix de l'organiser ou
pas nabila taboury mathias barrois ça a
la couleur de l'école le goût de l'école
mais ce n'est pas l'école plutôt une
journée 213 question service minimum
maisons alfort villes de banlieue et
depuis elle crée maintenant rodée pour
cette deuxième journée de grève depuis
janvier les parents ont été prévenus il
ya quelques jours
ceux qui ont déposé leurs enfants ne
pouvaient pour la plupart faire
autrement qui copains enfin voilà
grands-parents sont pas disponibles ça
m'arrange pas d'arrangement gravats et
qu'est ce que vaut la saison
c'est pas bien pour les gens qui font la
grève huit essais sur fakate la grève
mais bon en tout 600 élèves accueillis
aujourd'hui ils étaient 400 janvier
dernier ici le service minimum commence
à faire secte pour payer le personnel
recevra 80 jusqu'où les salles et
retombera sur les salaires des
enseignants grévistes
quant aux agents qui s'occupent des
enfants aucun personnel non qualifié
aujourd'hui et aucun personnel j'insiste
bien qu'ils se substituent à la fonction
enseignante sont là au premier
enseignant se passe à paris et dans
cette école une partie des enseignants
est en grève
quand les parents ne peuvent pas les
garder les enfants sont dispatchés dans
les classes
ici pas de service minimum la mairie
socialiste et contre les parents peux tu
aimerais bien assez favorable que l'on
puisse être qu'ils soient encadrés
malgré tout pouvoir n'est pas
responsable nous des problèmes des
enseignants
le droit de grève s'est pas trop fait
droit de dire non plus pour ses hôtels
pied quoi ils sont obligés d'être 50
dans une classe pas pourquoi le système
d c'est la solution de la maman de julie
la fillette va passer sa journée chez
ses grands parents papis et mamies
plutôt que le contrôle de maths
forcément tu mens les ravit les vrais
m'arrange parce que je les vois globe du
sou passe pour l'avenir mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai pourquoi pas
puis de 2800 commune la plupart de
droite ont mis en place le service
minimum
c'est un peu plus de 10% des villes qui
ont une école et ce soir le président de
la république a donc annoncé un projet
de loi pour rendre ce service d'accueil
obligatoire dans toutes les communes une
loi qui par ailleurs imposera aussi aux
enseignants grévistes de se déclarer 48
heures à l'avancé
alexandre kara
non aux réductions d'effectifs dans
l'éducation c'était le slogan
aujourd'hui dans les manifestations
oui au service minimum c'est la réponse
de l'elysée en stratégie cela s'appelle
une contre attaque
j'ai demandé au gouvernement de déposer
avant l'été un projet de loi qui
instituera un droit à l'accueil des
enfants qui sont inscrits dans nos
écoles de ce projet de loi de service
minimum à l'école nicolas sarkozy a
dévoilé ce soir deux des principales
mesures
désormais les grévistes devront se
déclarer 48 heures avant la grève
d'autre part pour assurer les communes
le texte prévoit que c'est l'état qui
financera l'accueil des enfants
une annonce en forme de coup médiatique
clairement destiné aux parents d'élèves
le droit de grève c'est un droit garanti
par la constitution
mais le droit où travaillent pour les
familles qui n'ont pas les moyens de
faire garder leurs enfants
joe de grève ce droit aussi doit être
garantie
ce projet de loi devrait être présenté
rapidement par le ministère de
l'éducation
la question est maintenant de savoir
comment le texte sera accueilli par les
enseignants et apparemment l'annnonce de
nicolas sarkozy a pris beaucoup de monde
de court très peu de réaction ce soir
aucune réaction même politique ou
syndicale pour l'instant un dernier mot
de l'actualité sociale on évoquer tiers
la journée de grève contre l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation pour les
retraites ce sera jeudi prochain eh bien
ce sont finalement les huit syndicats la
sncf qui s'y associent ainsi que trois
syndicats de la ratp journée qui
s'annonce très difficile donc dans les
transports publics
on en vient à la situation en chine
après le tremblement de terre
avec d'abord une image d'espoir celle de
cette opération réussie pour les
sauveteurs une jeune femme de 22 ans a
été tirée des décombres après trois
jours passés sous les débris
claude sans peur ils ont d'abord vu une
main une main qui bougeait et puis ils
ont vu ses yeux est entendue sauf à
partir de là ce petit groupe de
secouriste a tout fait pour la sortir
des décombres
mais la tâche est extrêmement difficile
cette jeune femme est ensevelie sous les
ruines de son école depuis trois jours
et trois nuits
les secouristes lui donne de l'eau lui
parle constamment hélas parfois la force
de faire des signes de la main autour
d'elle les secours travaillent le plus
vite possible
j'attends qu'ils me sauver je suis sûr
qu'ils vont y arriver
comment vous avez résisté tout au début
j'avais entendu quelqu'un en dehors j'ai
trié écrié en vain et après comment ça
s'est passé
j'ai tout fait pour garder mes forces
j'avais faim soif j'essayais de rester
calmes et enfin les secours sont arrivés
quelques heures plus tard elle est enfin
sorti des décombres un simple bandeau
sur les yeux pour la protéger de la
lumière
elle est sauvée ailleurs l'espoir de
retrouver des survivants a fortement
diminué face aux équipes de télévisions
étrangères les chinois ne masquent pas
leur colère et leur chagrin
jérôme hermet à bout de nerfs à bout de
patience
cet homme pas sa colère sur les
secouristes
trois jours que ses parents d'élèves
campe autour de l'école de juyuan tous
le savent maintenant tout ce qu'ils
peuvent espérer c'est un corps sans vie
sur les 900 collégiens prise au piège 60
ont survécu c'est trop long en une demi
journée ils n'ont été capables de sortir
cocasses ou encore la colère et dans les
rumeurs vont bon train on s'interroge
pourquoi certains bâtiments autour ont
tenu bon
alors qu'il ne reste rien de l'école
elle a été construite en très peu de
temps
étage par étage à chaque fois qu'il
réunissait ses d'argent donc la base
n'était pas assez solide et l'immeuble
s'est effondré d'un coup sans même
tremblé avant les militaires mobilisés
sont de plus en plus nombreux 130000
aujourd'hui mais l'été les chinoises ont
beau diffuser ces images il est déjà
trop tard
ils sont des milliers à ne plus attendre
à descendre des montagnes ou rien
n'arrive
après le séisme j'ai un peu attendu et
puis j'ai compris ça fait deux jours que
je marche parce qu'il n'y a aucun
transport et que la situation est
vraiment trop mauvaise là ou là haut
la zone de l'épicentre et des villes des
villages que l'on disait détruit à 80 %
à certains endroits c'est plutôt cent
pour cent ici depuis le séisme ils n'ont
pas vu l'ombre d'un secours
en fait leurs premiers visiteurs sont
les journalistes allemands qui filme ces
images est précisément deux envoyés
spéciaux samah soula et tristan le braz
ont pu emprunter la route qui conduit
jusqu'à l'épicentre jusqu'à l'endroit où
les éboulements l'ont rendue
impraticable
voici leurs reportages
l'adieu de trois petites filles à leur
grand mère sur les décombres
les adolescentes improviste une
cérémonie funéraire de l'encens des
oranges en offrande et le corps est vite
emporté jusqu'au bout elle avait gardé
l'espoir de la retrouver et vente
soyez forte tant de gens vivent votre
douleur leur dit ce jeune homme les
secouristes ne dégage plus que des corps
sans vie pour cet enfant
ils ont pris le soin de déposer ses
chaussures pour l'identifier
la route vers l'épicentre du séisme
n'est qu'une succession de ruines niché
dans les montagnes
regardez on n'a plus rien et en plus on
n'a rien à manger
ici on ne déplore qu'un mort mais la
famille est totalement démuni ni eau ni
électricité et surtout pas les moyens de
reconstruire une maison
le gouvernement aide les sinistrés mais
il s'occupe d'abord de ceux qui sont
encore plus touchés que nous les cris de
joie c'est de la diam
une distribution de nourriture organisé
par des bénévoles en d une famille de 10
sur leur fourgonnette
il distribue des oeufs qui l'on te même
acheté un des nombreux gestes de
solidarité
mais des paysans comme on n'a pas grand
chose là on veut les aider
la route directe pour une chaîne
s'arrête ici
une cinquantaine de kilomètres avant
l'épicentre seuls les militaires et les
secours cessent pas si ceux qui veulent
absolument regagner les villages de
leurs proches se retrouvent sur ce pour
cette bénévole est à bout de nerfs et
link il ne faut plus tentés de s'y
rendre que c'est bien fou dangereux
j'ai besoin d'avoir des nouvelles
je suis inquiète au niveau de l'immense
barrage de zipingpu qui a subi de
sérieuses qui sur certains choisissent
de passer malgré tout né dans ses
montagnes ses hommes tant connaissent le
danger mais ils doivent distille ramener
de la nourriture à leurs familles à
partir de ce point pour commencer à
atteindre les villages sinistrés au
coeur de l'épicentre
il faut au moins huit heures d'ascension
avec des risques d'éboulements et de
glissements de terrain
mais c'est le seul moyen d'apporter
vivres et soins aux survivants
dernier élément je vous le disais sur la
situation en chine les autorités sont
inquiètes précisément pour la sécurité
des barrages près de 400 installations
hydrauliques présenterait des risques
renaud bernard un rempart en béton et
derrière plus d'un milliard de mètres
cubes d'eau
l'édifice n'a que deux ans mais il a
souffert il y à une brèche au milieu de
la paroisse ce barrage est proche de
l'épicentre du séisme
juste au dessus de la ville de
dujiangyan s'ils cèdent les six cent
mille habitants de la cité seront noyés
les villages tout autour engloutis pour
prévenir tout mouvement panique
les autorités chinoises ont ausculté les
ouvrages avec les premiers résultats
elles se veulent rassurantes les dégâts
n'a fait que la surface du barrage il ya
des fissures mais je peux vous garantir
qu'il n'y a pas de dommages structurels
l'édifice reste sur les autorités ont
dépêché deux mille militaires sur place
mais plusieurs autres édifices
sont dans un état préoccupant situé en
aval des centaines de retenue d'eau ont
été fragilisés par la secousse
et parmi les 22000 barrages que compte
la chine il y à celui des trois gorges
sur le fleuve yangtsé
situé à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de la zone la plus touchée
ce monument le plus important édifice
hydroélectrique du monde n'aurait pas
souffert
pékin affirme qu'il a été construit pour
résister à de fortes secousses
dernière information là encore c'est
sans doute le signal d'une certaine
volonté de transparence une première
équipe étrangère de secours a été
autorisé à se rendre sur place une
équipe japonaise constituée d'une
trentaine de pompiers de policiers et
d'experts en france une bonne nouvelle
pour l'économie
l'insee a révisé ses chiffres pour la
croissance et c'est une heureuse
surprise elle a retrouvé des couleurs au
premier trimestre 2008 +0 6%
les résultats de l'année 2007 ont
également été revus à la hausse
romain mais si pascal caron christine
lagarde avec le sourire pour annoncer la
bonne nouvelle du jour une croissance
2007 meilleur que prévu puisque 2,2 pour
cent selon l'insee au lieu de 1,9 à
chaque au même instant à matignon
françois fillon jubile c'est évidemment
une très très bonne nouvelle c'est
d'ailleurs une nouvelle qui confirme que
les prévisions du gouvernement était
parfaitement exact et ça montre que la
politique économique qui est conduite
par le gouvernement est la bonne une
croissance 2007 plus forte grâce aux
exportations et l'investissement des
entreprises
mais pour certains économistes l'analyse
des chiffres montrent que le
gouvernement n'y est pas pour grand
chose
c'est le premier sommet ce qui a été
fortement révisé à la hausse et c'est
effectivement avant la mise en place à
la fois du paquet fiscal et des autres
mesures mis en place par le gouvernement
fillon
donc c'est plus son envie d'air l'ancien
gouvernement qui est à féliciter
bataille de chiffres également avec
l'europe bruxelles critique un déficit
français à 3% l'an prochain christine
lagarde contre attaque
on les a annoncé très largement nos
prévisions de déficit public pour 2009
c'est 2,5 pour cent et non pas 3 %
optimiste après un bon premier trimestre
christine lagarde table toujours sur une
croissance proche de 2%
cette année et puis à l'heure où l'on
parle beaucoup et ici aussi des prix et
des difficultés l'insee a dévoilé une
autre indication qui va surprendre le
pouvoir d'achat a augmenté en moyenne en
2007 l'an dernier de 3 3% vous avez bien
lu 3 3% alors ce chiffre est-il
trompeurs ou bien est-ce l'impression
générale des français qui n'est pas
fidèle à la réalité bonsoir agnès
molinier vous avez rejoint et vous avez
des éléments de réponse oui david healy
a toujours une différence entre le
ressenti et la froideur des statistiques
et du point de vue statistique justement
il ya eu plusieurs éléments en 2007 qui
ont amélioré les chiffres d'abord le
chômage a reculé
il ya eu beaucoup d'emplois créés plus
de 300000 donc globalement plus de
salaires distribués mais au niveau du
ressenti justement pour tous ceux qui ne
sont pas concernés et notamment ceux qui
avaient déjà un emploi et bien
l'amélioration n'existe pas vraiment
autre élément statistique en 2007
globalement l'impôt sur le revenu a
baissé du fait de l'application de
diverses mesures
mais là encore si comme un ménage sur
deux vous ne payez pas alors évidemment
pour vous rien n'a changé
et enfin il est à la hausse des prix 3%
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup mais elle ne
s'est emballée qu'en fin d'année 2007 au
niveau du ressenti ce sont surtout les
augmentations ces derniers mois que l'on
retient et il ya fort à parier david que
cette inflation galopante ressentir en
ce moment va peser sur le pouvoir
d'achat statistiques en 2008 merci agnès
pour ces éléments le constat en tout cas
est bien là beaucoup de familles
semblent éprouver des difficultés
voici un exemple étonnant chaque jour
les supermarchés voit affluer au moment
de la sortie des poubelles des groupes
de personnes qui se disputent parfois
pour se partager les restes
signe des temps il n'y a pas que des
sans abri il ya aussi des salariés et
des retraités c'est le dossier de cette
édition
il est signée jenny briffa emmanuel
maurel
les poubelles du supermarché viennent à
peine d'être sortis et ils sont déjà
cinq à les vider avec application nous
l'avons fait pour moi trop cher trop
cher pour moi ils disent ne pas avoir le
choix
mais pour recueillir leurs témoignages
nous sommes obligés de les filmer en
caméra cachée on n'est pas des clochards
l ai pas d
voyez notre maison avait normalement
sans qu'on n'arrive pas à pas des
clochards les béhèmistes des retraités
ou même des salariés dépassé par la
hausse des prix
jacques à une formation de technicien
supérieur les à bientôt 60 ans ils ne
trouvent plus de travail
comment vous feriez pour les courses
sais pas comment je parcours non mais on
va acheter le minimum en bas c'est le
monde mangeait le minimum beaucoup
pratiquent beaucoup de rires mais
l'année le 12/13 déjà mettre mes
managers
tout ce que je prends ici apprend
batterie à la maison des fruits et
tournoi de la paix on a passé son
enfance à voile et juin jacques vient
ici à trois fois par semaine à chaque
fois il prend soin de nettoyer derrière
lui pour laisser place nette aux
éboueurs remplie qui se battent pour
avoir un quart à kaboul et à kunduz et
là c'est carrément les bottes de 20
points nous changeons d'arrondissement à
l'arrière d'un supermarché
six femmes attendent que les employés
sortent les poubelles ou en vieil c'est
pour manger cela pour voler non on ne
vole pas vingt quatre enfants afghans
quand tu peux vivre avec les 514 494
euros
le rmi ses enfants ignorent que ce
qu'ils mangent bien des poubelles c'est
pas c'est pas pour ouvrir mois pose bien
sûr j2ee un blues la base et l'opinion
coffre mesure qu'à ce moment là tête
ce n'est qu'au moment où les et voir
arrive que les employés du supermarché
sont censées sortir les poubelles
un moyen de décourager les glaneurs mais
ce jour là les éboueurs n'ont pas eu le
temps d'attendre les poubelles resteront
dans le magasin dans d'autres enseignes
on verse même de la javel sur la
nourriture dessus et la nourriture
ah oui et après vous faites 3 vous allez
quand même à paris selon les
associations
ils seraient plusieurs milliers à faire
les poubelles pour se nourrir
on en vient à l'actualité judiciaire
c'est un sujet douloureux et délicat qui
avait à traiter aujourd'hui le tribunal
administratif de limoges et qu'on
pourrait résumer ainsi faut-il
privilégier la vie à tout prix vingt-six
ans après les faits une mère à réclamer
réparation à l'hôpital après la
naissance de sa fille lourdement
handicapée le bébé en état de mort
cérébrale avait été réanimée contre la
volonté de ses parents
arnaud compte à l'inde à rire ensemble
elles sont venues réclamer réparation
depuis 26 ans depuis sa naissance c'est
l'audi ne quitte plus sa mère même ici
au tribunal en 1992 l'accouchement dany
amouriq est un calvaire
le bébé en état de mort apparente et
réanimé de force contre la volonté des
parents aujourd'hui elodie est
handicapée moteur et mental à 100% on
sait qu'elle a rien génétique donc sur
la dianétique pourquoi est elle peint
sans qu'on me dise pourquoi elle est
comme ça dans ce cas ci c'est pas faute
de fautes de faute de moyens qui n'était
pas présent je veux accuser personne et
qu'on reconnaisse on a ça l'avocat de la
famille dénonce des fautes en cascade
lors de l'accouchement qui a eu lieu
quinze jours après le terme de la
grossesse pour le centre hospitalier de
châteauroux
aucune erreur n'a été commise à l'époque
du moins
il faut aussi avoir présent à l'esprit
que l'on doit se placer en 1982 et
apprécier les pratiques les données de
la science à l'époque 1982 annie amouriq
a abandonné son travail depuis la mort
de son mari il ya huit ans elle s'occupe
seule d'elodie incontinentes est presque
aveugle
je suis content ratissant de douleur
toujours tu es toujours réelle du tout
hier au quotidien du ttp dijon on vivote
est bon pour le préjudice subi et pour
couvrir les frais de vie quotidienne de
sa fille annie réclame 6 millions
d'euros ce matin lors de l'audience le
commissaire du gouvernement
un magistrat indépendant a demandé le
rejet de cette requête
le tribunal administratif de limoges
tranchera dans une quinzaine de jours
alors cette affaire pose un problème de
principe mais aussi de pratiques
médicales
comment réagir quelles sont les règles
et les éléments d'appréciation
aujourd'hui
reportage aux et blanc lapierre patrice
bruel dans l'incubateur un bébé qui
vient de naître
hospitalisé de toute urgence pour un
problème respiratoire survenu dans la
salle de naissance n'a pas vu sa maman
dans un bloc ne pouvait pas y accéder
elle n'a vu que son papa
quand la venue au monde se compliquent
détresse respiratoire mauvaise
oxygénation du cerveau les médecins sont
unanimes la priorité est de sauver le
bébé
l'heure n'est pas aux questions un
enfant qui nait sont ce qu'on appelle en
état de mort apparente
si on veut lui donner une chance de
vivre il faut intervenir
question on se les posent après si on se
les posent avant c'est même pas la peine
de se les poser on perd du temps et
c'est sûr que là l'enfant des lésions
les questions donc on se les posent
après le nouveau né une fois confié aux
soins intensifs où il va subir toutes
sortes d'examens irm échographie du
cerveau électroencéphalogramme le but
est d'évaluer d'éventuelles séquelles et
dans ce cas peut-être de prendre une
décision
si on arrive à un pronostic clairement
défavorable la question se pose de
savoir si on poursuit ses soins de
réanimation et de discuter avec les
parents du bien fondé de la poursuite de
ces soins de réanimation dans la mesure
où on a la certitude où la quasi
certitude que cet enfant dans sera un
grand handicap et scène sur lui en vingt
ans beaucoup de choses ont changé dans
l'accompagnement des nouveaux nés
arrivent les progrès dans l'évaluation
des séquelles une plus grande
participation des parents et puis une
loi en 2005 qui dit non à l'acharnement
thérapeutique à l'étranger un nouveau
soutien pour barack obama aux états unis
celui de son ancien rival dans la course
à l'investiture démocrate john edwards
en italie silvio berlusconi avait fait
de la lutte contre les clandestins l'un
de ses thèmes de campagne et bien à
peine arrivé au pouvoir
la police le gouvernement a mené une
vaste opération la nuit dernière
dirigées notamment contre les roms qui
avait focalisé l'attention depuis
quelques semaines correspondance karine
comazzi clara bosco à naples voilà
comment se termine la chasse aux roms
une habitante de ce qu'on avait tenté
d'enlever un bébé les riverains ont
lancé des cocktails molotov et fait fuir
toute la communauté
on a gagné crise est fan demain je
prends mes cinq enfants et on rentre en
roumanie ça vous va est bonne et la
communauté rom est aussi dans le
collimateur de la police italienne
la nuit dernière 50 personnes ont été
interpellées dans le plus grand camp de
nomades de la banlieue de rome faux
papiers voiture volée des personnes ont
été immédiatement expulsé
la police italienne a assuré que la
communauté rom n'est pas
particulièrement visée est que ces
arrestations s'inscrivent dans une plus
vaste opération de lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
mais les mesures annoncées par le
ministre de l'intérieur membre du parti
xénophobe la ligue du nord semble viser
particulièrement les nomades sera
expulsé toute personne qui n'a pas de
revenus légaux et de logement décent
des mesures qui inquiètent son homologue
romain venu spécialement à rome pour des
éclaircissements
ce soir le temps est à l'apaisement du
clos m 6 qu'il n'y a pas de problème
avec la roumanie
mais avec les délinquants a expliqué le
ministre de l'intérieur en somme les
premiers pas d'un gouvernement élu sur
la question sécuritaire
en bref encore à l'étranger accord en
vue pour une sortie de crise au liban
sous l'égide de la ligue arabe face au
hezbollah le gouvernement pro occidental
a en fait totalement reculé en annulant
les deux décisions qui visait l'emprise
du parti chiite qui visait à lutter
contre cette emprise
ce soir les barrages sur la route de
l'aéroport ont été levées et puis ont
parlé ces derniers jours du soixantième
anniversaire de la création de l'état
d'israël côté palestinien ce jour-là
représente une catastrophe
appelez là bas la nakba lorsque des
centaines de milliers de personnes ont
quitté leur terre des commémorations
étaient organisées aujourd'hui vous le
voyez en cisjordanie et à gaza en france
la discussion d'un projet de loi qui
concerne au premier plan les
journalistes mais au delà le droit à
l'information en général
de quoi s'agit-il du secret des sources
en clair peut-on exiger d'un journaliste
qu'il révèle le nom de la ou des
personnes qui lui ont donné une
information au risque de compromettre
ses contacts et donc son travail s
justifiable dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce texte oriali
main daniel
c'était un matin de décembre à l'heure
du laitier
guillaume dasquié journaliste
d'investigation a vu débarquer chez lui
six policiers de la direction de la
surveillance du territoire
cinq heures de perquisition à son
domicile et 36 heures de garde à vue
pour avoir diffusé dans un article sur
les attentats du 11 septembre des
renseignements classés secret défense
objectif des policiers ce jour-là
identifier ses sources
ils vont tenter de multiples pressions
et des pressions à la détention
donc il me menace de me mettre en prison
pour avoir un début de commencement
d'idées sur qui pourrait être ma source
ou à défaut qui pourrait avoir sorti ces
fameux documents de la dgse
engagement de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy le projet de loi sur le secret
des sources des journalistes a été
débattu aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
objectif protéger ce secret mais aussi
l'encadré ma conviction est que le
secret des sources doit pouvoir être
levée dans certaines conditions
extrêmement encadré il ne peut pas être
absolue selon le projet le secret pourra
être relevée lorsqu un intérêt impérieux
l'imposent trop vague
selon certaines voix les notions telles
que intérêt général nécessité impérieuse
qui va en décider ça affaiblit le
principe de protection des sources des
journalistes
au lieu de le renforcer mais pour la
majorité ce texte est un progrès il
vient combler un manque
là où il n'y avait pas de textes où il y
avait une vraie difficulté depuis 1996
pour tous les journalistes et où il
vivait dans l'insécurité par rapport à
leurs sources
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ils vont avoir
la possibilité de travailler dans une
vraie sécurité avec des exceptions bien
cadrer ce projet qui interdira désormais
les perquisitions dans les rédactions et
au domicile des journalistes pourraient
être adoptées dès ce soir
en bref après son rejet surprise par
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi
sur les ogm a été rétabli hier soir en
commission mixte paritaire toujours à
l'assemblée il sera à nouveau proposée
au vote
à la fin du mois ainsi qu'au sénat les
sciences avec cette découverte
géologique la méditerranée c'est bien
asséché il y a cinq millions d'années le
détroit de gibraltar avait alors été
obstruées voilà qui explique le dépôt
d'épaisses couches de sel au fond de la
mer et aussi les gisements de pétrole
déceler plus en profondeur
agnès monteux avec notre bureau à lyon
on la savait belle
le joyau des mers européennes mais la
méditerranée russell peut-être un autre
trésor enfoui dans ses entrailles
l'or noir le pétrole prisonniers sous
une épaisse couche de sel à 6000 mètres
de profondeur tout a commencé il ya six
millions d'années avec d'énormes
tremblement de terre
la plaque africaine pouces europe les
détroits qui alimente la méditerranée
par les eaux atlantiques se bouche
il fait très chaud trois degrés de plus
qu'aujourd'hui
en 1500 ans la mère a disparu évaporé ne
reste qu'une épaisse couche de sel
depuis bien sur l'eau est revenue
est ce celle en flux aujourd'hui sous
2000 mètres de sédiments est invisible
mais les scientifiques viennent de
prouver son existence et espère
maintenant pouvoir percer cette croûte
de sel de 3 km sous laquelle se
trouverait peut-être du pétrole
prisonniers de cette chatte
c'était la grande énigme un dans la
mesure où on sait que chaque fois que
les navires des grands forage
internationaux ont touché le sommet de
ces roches salines il ya eu des
remontées d'hydrocarbures dans le
quartier et seul un bateau japonais le
chic you peu fort est aussi profond sans
risquer de déclencher marée noire l'idée
serait de dépasser ces massives couche
de sel à deux endroits au large de la
france et de chypre
certains spécialistes américains
estiment qu'il y aurait des milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz sous la méditerranée
mais tous ne sont pas d'accord patience
il faudra attendre au moins six ans pour
savoir si ce trésor englouti existe bien
le festival de cannes au centre des
regards pour la monter les marches ce
soir angelina jolie qui était notre
invité hier accompagnée de brad pitt et
de dustin hoffman qui était également
avec nous pour la présentation du film
hors compétition
kung fu panda un dessin animé dans
lesquels ils réalisent les voies cannes
qui s'apprête à célébrer un anniversaire
celui de la quinzaine des réalisateurs
sur la croisette pascal deschamps nadine
picard
47 la croisette le qg de la quinzaine
dès ce matin se pressait une foule
d'anonymes prêt à dévorer 40 films en
quinze jours pour fêter un événement
vieux de 40 ans mais au fait pourquoi 40
ans ces dames est ce que vous savez
quand et pourquoi la quinzaine a été
créée par mai 68 sous les pavés la plage
pas seulement à cannes un groupe de
réalisateurs et non des moindres obtient
l'arrêt du festival
par solidarité ou par solidarité avec
les étudiants et les ouvriers et vous me
parlez chrono la société des
réalisateurs voit le jour et créer un
nouveau festival sans compétition la
quinzaine s'appelait alors cinéma en
liberté ce qui s'est passé à ce moment
là c'était le fait de sortir d'un côté
ambassadeurs d'un côté très officiel
académique du cinéma et qui a créé la
quinzaine a été ensuite récupéré par le
festival officiel la quinzaine sera
ainsi la première à exposer à la lumière
les films de ken loach jarmusch ou les
frères dardenne et bien d'autres devenu
plus que célèbre party scorsese et avec
l ouverture de la quinzaine et à
l'époque c'était la première fois que
scorsese et de niro venait à cannes et
c'était à l'épaule de parfaite inconnue
à la quinzaine
ni smoking nibards dessus de toutes les
couleurs pour assister aux projections
il suffit de payer 5 euros la séance les
spectateurs viennent par milliers du
monde entier avec un spermatozoïde sa
nage
au programme cette année d'audacieux
film français argentins belge philippins
et polonais après 17 ans d'absence
jay-z skolimow qui présente quatre nuits
avec anna des compétitions des
récompenses j'ai déjà vécu tout ça
ces sites web mais faire l'ouverture de
la quinzaine c'est une situation idéale
pour moi
frères ennemis au départ la quinzaine le
festival officiel concours tu
aujourd'hui à faire de cannes une
vitrine exceptionnelle une image de
football le zenit saint pétersbourg a
remporté hier soir la coupe de l'uefa
les russes se sont imposés à manchester
face aux glasgow rangers 2e à 0 but
signé des mises off et zyryanov saint
pétersbourg qui avait éliminé marseille
qui en marge du match des incidents ont
éclaté entre les supporters des rangers
et les forces de l'ordre un supporter
russe a été poignardé à ses jours ne
sont pas en danger il est hospitalisé à
la police a procédé à une trentaine
d'interpellations pour terminer un mot
du grand rendez vous politique de la
soirée en direct bonsoir arlette chabot
ce soir dans à vous de juger vous
recevez notamment bernard kouchner
autour d'une grande question
sarkozy en deux ans coiffée au tilt
s'attendre oui d'abord après un an passé
au quai d'orsay on demandera bernard
kouchner silva bien s'il arrive à
concilier son souci des droits de
l'homme et la diplomatie traditionnelle
on lui demandera évidemment s'il est
toujours de gauche comment il se sent
plus ou moins à l'aise au sein d'un
gouvernement dit de droite
il sera également confronté à pierre
moscovici et puis en évoquant l'an 2
nicolas sarkozy bat bien sûr ce soir
nous parlerons de la grande information
c'est à dire l'annoncé par le président
de la république de la création d'un
service minimum d'accueil dans les
écoles en cas de grève
débat un peu chaud garanties notamment
entre julien dray et nathalie kosciusko
morizet avec les rédactions des
syndicalistes des profs ce soir donc
bernard kouchner
et puis ensuite le débat sur
effectivement l'an 2 de nicolas sarkozy
avec bien sûr pour vous téléspectateurs
la possibilité de poser des questions
voilà le numéro de téléphone et on se
retrouve david avait voué aux autres
j'espère dans quelques minutes à tout de
suite
arlette avant de refermer cette édition
je vous rappelle précisément à l'un de
ses principaux titres au soir de cette
journée de grève et de manifestation des
fonctionnaires à des enseignants nicolas
sarkozy annonce que le service minimum
d'accueil facultative jusque là sera
obligatoire
les communes un projet de loi sera
déposé avant l'été premières réactions à
chaud
celle de françois hollande nicolas
sarkozy veut ouvrir une épreuve de force
inutile et blessantes et diviser les
français c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi vous avez sans
doute pu le constater il a été réalisé
dans des conditions particulières en
raison d'une journée d'action pour le
service public
tout de suite la météo tania young point
road valérie maurice 20h50 donc à vous
de juger très bonne soirée
be nice